hey what's up welcome back to my channel
my name is samuel leeds i'm a property
investor and in this video good news is
i'm going to be answering all of your
property investment questions so how's
this going to work well the first thing
you need to do to play the game is smash
the like button that'd be absolutely
amazing go ahead and smash that right
now it doesn't cost anything to smash
the like button you don't lose anything
so do that right now and then if you've
got questions around property investment
all we need to do is comment them below
and i'm going to answer your niggling
property investment questions now i've
got a few questions from last week so
i'm going to go ahead and read these and
answer these and while i'm doing that if
your question pops into your mind go
ahead comment it below and next week i
will try my best to answer all of your
property investment questions so someone
here says this is cynic exotic hi samuel
just a quick question does it make sense
to buy a house to live in
with a interest only mortgage
great question um i think it does make
sense to do that generally speaking i'm
gonna
hold off paying my debts as long as i
possibly can so if i've got a mortgage
let's say i'm moving to a house and the
mortgage is
200 000 pounds i'm not going to rush to
pay that down
the whole way that we've been programmed
in society to live is pay off debts pay
off debts pay off debts but actually i
don't think that the goal is to be debt
free i think the goal is to be
financially free
remember that one financially free is
where your passive income covers your
living expenses that's the goal that's
it and if you're focusing on being debt
free even if you become debt free even
if you get to a point in life where
you've paid off the mortgage you're
living in a house it's all paid off and
you're debt free you've got a car that
you own out right and you get free but
it doesn't really help because you still
got to eat you still got to live you've
still got to go on holiday how you going
to afford to do that so the goal is to
have enough passive income that covers
your life and that passive income can
pay the mortgage payments can pay the
car can pay your food can pay your
holiday financially free so generally
speaking before becoming debt free i'll
be coming financially free um however
most residential lenders are
usually want you to to to pay on a
repayment mortgage so i think either way
is okay the only exception is if you
love the house and you just feel like
you know what i just want to own this
outright one day nothing wrong with
repayment mortgages for buy to let's
generally interest only is better in my
opinion because you've got more cash
flow so it really is a personal decision
hope that helps david cook
i have nothing
but want to start my own company or
business is that possible says david
cook
well
it costs about 12 pounds to start a
company on company's house so if you
have nothing do you have 12 pounds
technically you can start a company for
12 pounds you can do it yourself on
companies house but the real definition
of a business is not just having a
limited company on companies house the
real definition of a business is having
something which is making money so can
you start with no money i would say
absolutely yes based on the fact that
i started all of my companies with no
money i never got a
business loan from a bank to start my
companies all of them have been my
letting agency my construction company
my buy to let company my training
company it was all started from nothing
the thing is this
if you want to make money through
business you have to find a way of
adding value so let's say you want to
get into property and you've got nothing
you literally and you don't even got the
12 pounds to set up a company the
question is
how can you
as a sole trader as just a person how
can you add value to people's lives how
can you help other people make money
maybe maybe you could go to estate
agents and start hustling and finding
cheap properties and then introduce
these cheap properties to investors and
guess what you're going to do if you do
that you're going to get paid
you're going to get paid to do that do
you have to have money to do that no
so i don't really think you need money
to start a business and there's millions
of successful businesses across the
planet that started with no money what
you need is you need creativity and you
need a good idea and you need a good
business plan so i hope that helps good
luck
music how can i find good deals in this
hot market what a great question i was
actually chatting with one of my friends
earlier and martin and mark was saying
to me that they just bought a property
and it was literally on the open market
they bought it for 215 000 pounds and i
said to them i asked them the same
question i said how did you buy it and
get it such a good deal
when the market's so hot it's in an open
market why did you not get out bit like
most people are complaining and they
said this this is really interesting
they said they didn't buy a property
that was going to be instantly a good
deal with a good return on investment
but they could see
that there was value to be added to the
property they're turning this property
into flats so it's one property they're
going to turn it into three flats
so
if you want to find good deals in this
marketplace right now while the market's
hard rather than trying to find
something that's going to give you an
instantly good return you need to be
finding opportunities that most people
can't see you need to be finding ways to
add value to properties that most people
might not be able to find for instance
find properties where there's there's um
a side plot you know or there's a garage
next to the house where you think
no one's noticed but i could potentially
get planning permission
to build another house next door
or find a property that's got a long
garden where potentially you could build
at the back of the garden or find a
property that is run down
and it's got strip it's got structural
problems and no one wants to touch it
but you know actually it's only going to
cost a few thousand pounds to get this
put right so rather than trying to find
good deals
you need to be good yourself you need to
become a good property problem solver be
able to find problems
where you can fix that problem and then
it becomes an opportunity when you get
good that's when you start finding good
deals jim rohn said don't wish it was
easier wish you were better and that's
so true in today's market when there's
so many people saying it's hard to find
a deal it's hard to find a deal so i
don't wish it was easier to find a deal
wish you were better at finding deals
wish you had more skills to spot the
opportunities so i think that's probably
what i would say because there's always
deals out there there's right now
there's loads of opportunities but you
need to be able to be trained well
enough to be able to spot those deals
hope that helps all right last question
don't forget folks i want to know your
questions so comment below this is from
alan partridge um allen said i wanted to
become a deal finder but it seems that
every man and his dog is one now surely
the market doesn't need tens of
thousands of deal finders surely it's
well over saturated now
that's a great question alan um i think
i'd probably say i'll answer that in a
few parts firstly there's lots of deal
finders out there yes but is there tens
of thousands of really good ones
i'm not sure there is i mean right now
you say every man on his dog is a deal
finder
i think right now every man in his dog
is desperately looking to get a good
deal but can't find one so that we're in
desperate need of good deal finders
another thing is as well we deal with
deal sources
is the way i see it i almost see a deal
sourcer a little bit like um
it's part of your power team when you're
buying a property when you're buying a
property you need a mortgage broker
what's the mortgage broker's job the
mortgage broker's job is to find you a
good mortgage
now you could say
well why don't you find your own
mortgage because it's easier and more
convenient to pay a mortgage advisor or
a mortgage broker to just go out
scan the market and say i found you this
that i found you this mortgage
you could find it yourself you could go
into all the banks yourself individually
but you're paying for a service which is
going to make your life easier same with
a letting agent why don't you just
manage it yourself why don't you just
and the deal source is the same
when i'm paying a deal sourcer or a deal
finder i'm paying them because they've
gone out there on a tuesday afternoon in
the rain and they've viewed 20
properties
and they've chosen the best one and
they've negotiated a good price and i'm
paying them because i don't want to go
out in the rain on a tuesday afternoon
and view 20 houses so it's part of a
power team and every time i mean i don't
use deal sources every time i buy a deal
sometimes i'll find it myself sometimes
i'll join venture but every time some
investors
need need to buy property and there's a
lot of people buying a lot of deals
right now
that they might use a deal source again
and again and again and again that's my
that's my answer i hope that makes sense
so if you want to be a deal sorcerer but
you're thinking oh man there's loads
what's the point again what i would
probably advise you to do is say how can
i become the best
because believe me if you're the best or
even in the top 10
if you're one of the best deal finders
out there then people are going to pay
you because you're the best so don't
worry about the competition worry about
being the best
so i think the theme here is how do you
find good deals become a good deal
finder how do you become a good deal
finder practice training
you know get better at your craft
property investing is a business it's a
business so who's going to win
the people that are luckiest no the
people that are good at running the
business
your house
the houses that you find are your
products and your tenants or your
customers or your investors or your
customers so you've got to understand
marketing sales how to speak to agents
on market off market planning without a
plan you've got to really understand the
business
immerse yourself in it and then you're
going to start making money in this
industry so i do youtube videos all the
time three times a week on a sunday a
monday and a wednesday trying to give
tips and help people get better
more skilled as a property investor so
if you appreciate my channel if you
appreciate this video hit the like
button drop your question below and i
look forward to helping you get better
next time on my next video
also if you want to come and attend a
training day with myself i'm running a
one-day property training program myself
i'm going to be running the program now
there's good news and bad news the good
news is it's free to attend i've got
free tickets the bad news is we've got
very limited spaces so if you want to
attend get booked right now before we
sell out and i'll leave a link in the
description thanks for watching
[Music]
you